[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: Hi, Dino here.
In this video, we will get to
know Apigee's API analytics.
There are three big pieces
to managing an API program--
exposing your APIs, enabling
others to consume your APIs,
and then measuring
that activity.
APIs are foundational
for digital business,
so it's very important to
have complete visibility
into API performance.
You want to track developer
usage, API usage trends, error
rates, geographic distribution.
All of these metrics and
more are available to you
through the Apigee
Edge platform so you
can analyze your digital
business in real time.
Let me show you some
of what you get.
Navigate to the analytics
menu on the left-hand side.
Let's take a look.
The API proxy
performance chart will
show traffic volumes and
response times for your APIs.
This is such valuable insight.
Some customers create an Apigee
pass-through proxy on existing
services just to get this view.
You can view data for a
specific proxy or all proxies.
Look back an hour, a
day, a week, or more.
And it's built-in.
You don't have to do anything
to get this, so nice.
This report can be a great
resource for your developers
and DevOps team.
The cache performance
chart shows
utilization of the
built-in Apigee Edge
cache for your APIs.
This is really handy
for helping to optimize
performance and efficiency.
The geomap shows you the
geographic source of traffic.
It's marvelous to be able to
track API proxy usage by geo
to see where usage originates.
The latency analysis
chart is invaluable
when managing to a
response time goal.
Stable performance is key for
a quality user experience.
This Apigee chart shows
TP 50, TP 95, and TP 99.
That's average response
time as well as
95th and 99th percentile.
When you have
spikes in TP 99, it
indicates that other
pieces in your system
are not delivering stable
performance under load.
This chart pinpoints
that problem.
The traffic composition report
shows you the top proxies,
products, apps, or developers
by traffic volumes,
obviously valuable when
managing an API program.
And you can create
your own custom reports
based on the
individual metrics that
are collected by Apigee Edge,
like latency, IP address, path,
and response status code.
This is just a quick sample.
To get these charts for your
traffic, all you need to do
is create an API proxy in
Apigee Edge and direct client
applications to use it.
And of course, all of the
data presented visually
in these charts is
available via an API,
so you can export it into
your own analysis tools.
OK, that's the
quick introduction
to Apigee Edge analytics.
It gives you visibility into
key performance and operating
metrics for your APIs.
And if you want to know
more, dive into the product
documentation or
visit the community.
Until next time,
keep it digital.
[MUSIC PLAYING]